is King James really taking his talent
out of South Beach or is this just a
negotiating tactic I can't see him leave
in Miami you know how we like surprise
what would the surprise would be in this
story is if LeBron said I'm staying with
the two years I have left if he didn't
opt out that would be why walk me
through this he has two years and about
40 million dollars left on his deal
salary cap is going up there for the
maximum salary will go up by opting out
you can get a longer term deal at a
higher annual salary as well as here's
the important part the heat as
constituted are strapped they cannot add
too many pieces to a team that lost in
the finals what do you mean too many
pieces too many free agents to upgrade
the roster they need better players they
need a better supporting cast but if
LeBron ops out if Dwyane Wade opt out
and if Chris Bosh opt out the big three
which they all will do okay so LeBron
has already opted out you see the other
two rain and Chris will follow not like
that Dwayne and Chris will follow and
LeBron is going to pressure those two
guys to say you guys will take the
salary hit you're going to take a little
bit less on your deal maybe get more
years but take a little bit less
annually so that we can upgrade the
roster and win more championships and
those who are going to say yes King
James I'll take that that's exactly what
they will say because because Dwyane
Wade knows he's the best fit in Miami he
wants to be in Miami he's the franchise
player Miami been there forever they
will reward him with more years probably
a four-year deal let's say that other
franchises will not give a guy with
bulky knees Miami wants him to stay and
treat him well but his annual salary
will shrink from about 20 to 10 but
LeBron isn't going to make any
compromises any sacrifices he mighty
take a sliver of a haircut to say look
I'm giving as well perhaps because it's
a sudden su sort of thing the general
has to be treated like everybody else
maybe he'll take a sliver and he'll make
it up on the other end if he wins but
it's not going to be a bigger number
does this help or hurt the Heat's
ability to sign this Anthony oh he
didn't forget it's not happening well I
know it he makes too much money it's not
it you cannot have my money playing for
a non winning team well so let him go to
Chicago or Houston if we want to play
pipe dream where with LeBron go if
does leave Miami okay cremello now now
we're talking lebron lebron everybody
has to take a peek at LeBron he's the
best player on the planet three real
options stay in Miami the Houston
Rockets are the Chicago Bulls if he
wants to win right away Chicago may be
the best option but you know Chicago on
a they're going to want an answer
quickly and if not they'll move to
Carmelo Anthony same with Houston right
now when I would say Carmelo had about
24 hours is the best free agent on the
market now it's LeBron so he'll have to
wait till LeBron makes his decision so
again your Carmelo right now are you
sitting there feeling like a sitting
duck I can't believe this just happened
to me or any baby news he knew he knew
and there aren't too many players for
whom carmella can subjugate his ego
you've got no choice when it's LeBron
James he's done everything that Kamala
wants to achieve so he knows right now
he's planned me for everybody this can
we get LeBron but they don't think it's
gonna happen I I would peg it at 97 23
that he stays in Miami there is no
chance he takes his talent back to Ohio
his home state I cannot envision a
scenario beach once you are the king of
Miami sitting between Marc Anthony and
pitbull you anko's also got a rookie
coach now Dave Blatt going to Cleveland
you've got a point guard in Kyrie Irving
who has seemingly expressed some
interest in going elsewhere of course if
LeBron would to go that would maybe
change his mind but it's just not a
winning scenario right now there are
better scenarios from LeBron James to
achieve his goals and there's only one
win win win that's it well there you go
win win win and get paid hey that's
gonna happen no matter where he goes if
he will get paid oh this is just timing
when we got this announcement this is
for you zero surprise we knew this on
our state game of NBA chess is in full
effect right now absolutely that's it
there's not a single surprise in this
announcement watch for the other two to
come next and then let's see if they
take that bit of a pay cut so that they
can upgrade the roster and compete with
the San Antonio's little